okay thanks Joe thanks for the wonderful
introduction I'm happy to be back here
investor inspiration on this Friday and
you know it's a I joke about today being
order flow Friday because it seems like
all the presentations they are geared
towards order flow which is fantastic
you know because I believe waterfall
really is the way to understand what's
happening in the markets and today I
will be talking about uncovering hidden
movements in the market with order flow
and my goal for you today is to show you
how to get an edge over other traders by
seeing what they don't see I'm gonna
explain what our hidden price movements
and how to see them and we'll talk about
what no one will tell you about becoming
a successful trader now for those of you
that aren't familiar with me or this
movie the first time you're watching one
of my presentations I'll explain Who I
am again my name is Mike Koval tose and
I've been in the futures industry for
over 25 years basically and I started on
the CMA floor as a runner with Dean
Witter and back in those days in the
early 90s there was still a trading for
trading floor and it was very easy to
get into the industry because that's
that was the the easiest way to get into
the futures trading industry and the
very bottom is becoming a runner you
know a runner would be someone that
would take an order run it into the
trading pit through the floor broker and
that's how I got started you know
unfortunately these days really to get
started in the trading business you have
to go to a top university have a degree
in you know computer science and applied
mathematics and go through a big series
of tests to get accepted but you know
that's why I like doing these
presentations because it's sort of a way
of giving back you know some of my
knowledge that I've gained over the
years for people that aren't able to go
that route you know that that aren't
computer whizzes or mathematical whizzes
and you know want to get into trading so
I left the trading floor after being
there for about two years to work on the
upstairs trading desk at Dean Witter
because I realized that training was
going electronic and we had just started
up Globex
at the CME cbot had project a at that
time and nymex Comex had what was called
the access system and they needed people
to trade that stuff
I left train for to go work upstairs and
do that I worked in the middle and you
know overnight that come in at 10 p.m.
and leave at 8:30 in the morning and you
know it's a great exposure to not only
you know other markets but as well as
the international markets you know I was
became exposed to the Asian markets you
know the Nikkei JGBs
hang sang as well as the European
markets you know the life Mattia which
was the French markets DTB which later
became your ex now I left Dean Witter
and I joined ETF man I spent two years
there on the global macro trading desk
you know EDF man is a big English
trading company it was founded in the
late 1700s and still around but you know
that gave me a lot of additional
exposure to commodity markets after EDF
managed own joint Commerce Bank in
Chicago as their license directs trader
you know yeah those days you had to pass
a very difficult trading exam on you
know everything from futures to options
it's not like the series 3 or series 7
here in the US some universities there
in Europe use that your X exam as a
prerequisite to getting accepted into
their master's program after that I
joined cargo cargo is the big commodity
privately held commodity company in the
United States you know if it was a
publicly listed company you'd probably
be like the fourth largest in the United
States and they account for about 25 or
30 percent of grain exports and about 20
percent of meat exports from the United
States but they're also involved in all
the other commodities from oil the palm
oil to pretty much anything that's
traded that you know that can be grown
out of the ground or dug out of the
ground and then I spent eight years at
JP Morgan as vice president of Futures
Trading no I said on the trading desk I
didn't sit in some corner office that's
what he did every morning I'd come in at
5:00 in the morning
and I'd say that about 4:30 in the
afternoon and you know on the training
that's trading that's what I did day in
day out for eight years then I left JP
Morgan after my daughter was born
because I want to spend more time with
my family and in 2015 I started up order
flows calm which is a software company
you know we put out the order flows
trader software which runs on
ninjatrader we also have a version for
sierra charts under emoji trading and
basically what I want to do is I want to
take my knowledge and apply it to you
know put it in a form that you know
other users can use my knowledge and I
said you know a lot of people aren't
going to have this institutional
background that I have and it's not
something that's readily shared by a lot
of people so that's why I like to do
these presentations so I could give
people an insight into how the
institutional traders operates and how
you can see what's happening at the
institutional level in the market
through order flow so what I'm
presenting here is what I've developed
for myself and built my trading career
on and hopefully you can find things
that you can use or things you can
modify and adapt for your own trading
you know I'm not saying that you have to
follow what I say just because I say it
you have to evaluate everything you come
across whether it's from me or one of
the other speakers here today and decide
if it's gonna help you if not reject it
you know trading I always feel the
trading is a journey alright and you
have to grow as a trader you have to
learn new things find what works what
resonates with you and you could apply
for your training to become a better
trader you know it's not it's not a case
of picking up a book on the markets
reading it and committing at the memory
every sort of chart pattern that's ever
been devised and say this is it I'm
gonna be the master trader no you know
the way to approach it is you learn
everything you can take what makes sense
to you that you can use in your training
and apply it to your trading you know
it's not like you know you just turned
one year in college and that's it you
got a college degree you ready to do
everything in life no you know you take
all different courses and you maybe take
some things that you learn from one
person one teacher one professor and
take some other things from another
professor and it that's how you build
your foundation and let me be clear
right with trading you have to make
decisions you know
that's what trading is about you know
people like to buy indicators and think
it's some magic formula that's going to
turn the computer into a cash machine
you know an indicator is not a trading
system an indicator is something that
solves a particular problem or form of
analysis in the market under certain
conditions you know lots of times people
buy indicators thinking that's it you
know they bought a trading system ones
really not you know a full-blown trading
systems got a lot of a lot more bells
and whistles than just a trading an
indicator but the point is when you know
how to read the market you don't need
indicators you don't need trading
systems you are the trading system and
when you understand order flow you
understand the market what's happening
in the market and the decisions are
gonna become crystal clear you know what
would you at this discussion last night
was somebody about the self-driving cars
you know I think it's better to drive
your own car than having a self driven
car and you know that the point is why
it's because you know you're gonna be
able to react faster than a self driven
car you know and honestly I like you
know the whole thing of humans versus
robots is is a whole nother discussion
but you know when if I'm gonna put my
life you know on the line I want to have
control over it you know not some robot
car so in training and it's the same you
know once you learn how to trade yeah
because honestly you know people have
been trading for hundreds of years
people have made big fortunes trading
okay and if it was easy to just program
it into a computer then you know the
markets would never move there'd be no
edge anywhere because computers would
just be able to define that that
discrepancy price discrepancy and it
would just cancel itself out you know it
would no longer be there but you know
trading is based on human emotions it's
based on what people think of value now
versus what they think of value in the
future and when you understand you know
how the markets move why they move how
people think about the markets and
seeing it seeing it firsthand in the
order flow I think that makes all the
difference in the world so before I
begin let me
just go over brief disclaimer this
presentations for educational and
informational purposes only and should
not be considered a solicitation to buy
or sell a futures contract or make any
other type of investment decision
futures trading contain substantial risk
is not for every investor an investor
could potentially lose all or more than
the initial investment risk capital is
money that could be lost without
jeopardizing one's financial security or
lifestyle only risk capital should be
used for trading and only those with
sufficient risk capital should consider
trading past performance is not
necessarily indicative of future results
and again you know results vary because
no two people are going to approach the
markets the same way you know maybe um
you know maybe you're more risk-averse
than the person next to you or you know
maybe you don't have time to really
apply what you're trying to learn into
the markets or maybe it just doesn't
make sense that's why I say you know
watch the different presentations and
see what you know make sense to you that
you could apply to your to your trading
so let's jump into this so how to get an
edge over other traders you know
everyone like says you know to be
successful in the markets you have to
have an edge right but they don't really
talk about the edge you know though
they'll say buy low sell high that's not
an edge you you need to see things from
a perspective that other traders aren't
and I really believe that order flow is
gives you an edge it gives you that
insight into a market that other people
aren't paying attention to and the
information is available to all the
traders
it's just whether or not you want to
look at it and you know with basic order
flow with it with a footprint chart you
don't need level-2 level-3
data you just use the same information
that's put out by the exchange and what
order flow software will do is it'll put
it into an easy-to-read format and order
flow analysis provides the trader the
kind of advanced information that they
need to get an edge over other traders
which is basically the competition it's
about taking the money from the person
on the other end of the screen and
putting it in your pocket
you know the vast majority of traders
out there use a simple candlestick chart
like this okay now I admit you know I I
studied candles back in the in the 90s
when they first started becoming popular
and okay you know they work sometimes
honestly you know other certain patterns
I still like to train around but you
know it's there about as right as often
as they're wrong so you know is there an
edge and not really I for me there
hasn't been you know I mean like there's
several bars here that are very bullish
so are bearish like I'm looking at this
candle right here you know this is the
like a shooting star
yeah markets sold off in the next two
bars and rallied up made new high you
know yeah oh there's a doji and the
market sold off well okay I mean
honestly you could just pick a level
anywhere and trying to breakout off of
it whether it's the doji urn or not but
you know there just really wasn't
anything solid to get out of it you know
and and still people look at candles and
and they try to to look for something
that's never been discovered before okay
maybe you can but honestly you know I
think you're just going down a blind
alley now order flow it's gonna allow
you to see why a bar ended up a certain
way instead of just that the bar ended
up in a certain way you know with
candlesticks you're looking for
something like okay like here you have a
doji okay well what does that mean why
did it end up as a doji why is this bar
here as a shooting star and then it
failed and you know would have stopped
you out why you want to understand why
that's happening rather than just saying
oh okay there's a doji and there's a
shooting star you know I think it's
better to understand what's happening in
the market so the volume footprint
charge has been around for at least you
know at least a decade you know this is
2018 I think it goes back cuz it goes
back into the 90s you know that there's
been earlier versions and some other
software of it but the volume footprint
chart what does is it takes the data
what's traded on the bid what's traded
on the offer or what I mean is what is
the volume and puts into an easy-to-read
format that was gonna allow you to see
support and resistance it's gonna allow
you to tell if buying or selling is
weakening it's gonna allow you to see
where trap traders are if there's
divergence in the market where value is
if there's
imbalances and much more and when I
created the order flows trader software
now you know I'd been using another
company's footprint chart and yeah that
was fine but it was just a basic chart
you know it was just it was just the
basic information and what I wanted to
do why I created the order flows trader
software is because I wanted to take my
analysis and have it show up in the
chart so I didn't necessarily have to
sit here and try and decide if support
or resistance was here you know if
traders were trapped here if there was
divergence if there was market
imbalances appearing I wanted that
information to be shown to me on a chart
you know I'm a bit visual and I could
analyze it you know the human mind is a
fact human mind can process an image
much faster than I can
words or numbers you know text basically
so if I could take how I analyze the
market with the order flow and have it
appear on the chart you know with arrows
with different colors and whatnot then I
would rather do that then you know just
sit here and try and decide on a bar by
bar basis what's going on you know I
want the computer to do the work for me
now you know this is an age-old question
right why does the market move when
people say well the market moves because
there's more buyers than sellers I
literally read a book this morning a
trading book you know I love reading old
trading books and I've got a nice book
collection but it even said in that book
it said you know buyer markets move up
because there's more buyers than sellers
no it doesn't you know honestly if
you're every buyer there is a seller
okay but there's different types of
buyers and sellers now again you know if
for every buyer there was a seller the
market would never move it would just
stay in one spot right but what's
happening is what you have is more
aggressive buyers than aggressive
sellers and when we get that in a second
is once you understand the different
types of buyers and sellers and trading
you know it's like having a translation
dictionary because you're gonna
understand what's happening in the
market you know it's like going to a
foreign country not understanding the
language
then you know you start looking up the
words people are talking to you then
everything starts making sense and there
are four types of market participants
you have aggressive buyers aggressive
sellers passive buyers passive sellers
now aggressive buyers are the buyers who
buy at the market they lift the offer
aggressive sellers are sellers who sell
at the market they hit the bid passive
buyers are the ones who work a limit on
the bid or below the bid passive sellers
are sellers who work a limit on the
offer or above the offer so basically an
aggressive buyer wants to get into a
trade a passive seller
no they're not aggressive they they'll
let the market come to them and the best
way to think about it is is going to a
car dealer right you want to buy a car
you've got $15,000 cash on you to buy a
car but the car you want is twenty
thousand well you're gonna bid fifteen
thousand cars on offer at twenty
thousand well how's the trade gonna
happen is well the dealer's gonna decide
you know you know I've got I got a truck
full of cars coming in next week I gotta
move some of these cars so okay I'll
sell it to you at your bid price of
fifteen thousand now the South but the
car dealer is the seller
he's the aggressive seller he hits your
bid and if you're like - and dealers
like well you know what I can't move you
know I'm offered it at twenty thousand
like when I got fifteen thousand guys
like well come back when you got twenty
thousand you know no trades gonna happen
until you scrounge up that extra five
thousand and you become the aggressive
buyer and you buy it at twenty thousand
you know maybe you go home and you know
call your girlfriend or your wife and
say hey you got five thousand you can
let me so I get this car and you know
you're gonna be the aggressive one and
then you're gonna one that's the
aggressive buyer and you buy the car so
that's the difference between aggressive
buyers and aggressive sellers and
passive buyers and passive sellers now
by understanding the trading occurring
in the market between the aggressive
traders and the passive traders you gain
an understanding as to what's happening
in the market and any point in time we
get something to drink here now remember
going back to that statement you know
how do markets move well it's not
because everybody's a seller markets go
up because what you have is you have
more aggressive buyers than aggressive
sellers and the aggressive buyers are
buying all the passive sellers offers if
the market is six bit at seven and
there's fifty Lots on offer at seven the
aggressive buyers buy all 50 next thing
you know it's eight offer and they start
buying the eights once they buy all the
eights it's nine offer that's how the
market goes up is the aggressive buyers
buy all the available offers and keep
bidding the market up and going higher
and higher that's what makes a market
move up you know for market to move down
you have sellers selling all the selling
into all the bids that are there selling
it all till it's gone nobody's bidding
at that level next thing you know it's
one tick lower and so on and so on it's
that's what moves the market is when you
have more aggressive buyers lifting all
the addresses the passive sellers offers
markets move lower when all the when the
aggressive selling overwhelms the
passive buying so in 2015 when I created
the order flows business write the order
flows trader 2.0 is was the cornerstone
and it's the software that basically
what I wanted to do is take all the
different forms of order flow analysis
that I do put it into the software so it
can show me you know what's happening in
the market and the way I look at it as
you said it's it's not a full but it's
not a trading system it's not designed
to be a training system it's designed to
point things out to me in the market on
what's happening like hey idiot you know
don't miss that you know you could have
potential trap traders here or don't
miss that you could have market
imbalances appearing here that's why I
created it you know I I'm still the
trader right computers not the trader
I'm the one that's pulling the trigger
on the trades and you know we also I
also created several courses on order
flow trading basically the way I like to
describe it is basically like hanging
having me sitting down on on the
training desk next to you looking over
your shoulder telling you what's
happening in the market now there's many
different ways to use order flow like
there's no one way and there's many
people out there that I know they use
just one aspect of or
flow analysis and that's how they trade
that's how they make their daily nut you
know they make their you know eight
hundred nine hundred thousand dollars
and they call it a day that's it you
know they trade for a few hours just
look for specific to say patterns but
setups in the market and that's it they
take it till I hit that number and right
now I really feel like order flow is
picking the low-hanging fruits because
hedge funds at this point haven't really
gotten into using order flow analysis
the way you know they have with all
other forms of analysis and but that's
changing that's changing you know
different forms of order flows is just
basically a data point and soon you know
these hedge funds the good ones now I
know are getting into it and analyzing
different parts of order flow so I want
to talk about now is the different tools
that we have in the order flow trader to
allow you to see what other traders
can't see so the first one is marketing
balances and what's the market imbalance
is when there are more aggressive buyers
and sellers or vice versa yeah and what
I mean is in the two-way auction you
have more aggressive sellers and
aggressive buyers and why is that
important because that's what's going to
move the market and when you have an
imbalance that means you usually have at
least four to one ratio four times as
many aggressive buyers and aggressive
sellers at a point at a price level or
bid offer level in the bar selling
imbalance is the opposite when there's
at least four times as many traders
selling the bid and then traders buying
the offer now why is that important is
because well like I said you know a
markets gonna move lower when you have
more aggressive selling than aggressive
buying and a market is gonna move higher
when you have more aggressive buying
than aggressive selling that's what's
gonna cause the markets the move and in
the order flow trader a buying imbalance
in the volume footprint chart a buying a
balance is gonna be a blue number a
selling a balance is going to be a red
number a normal trade on the two-way
auction is just gonna be a black number
okay then you notice the majority of the
numbers are black that's because no one
is necessarily in control even though
you'll have more volume on one side or
the other it's not an imbalance right
it's just what you're viewing imbalance
is one of markets you know think of a
scale right you know something is kind
of evenly distributed but you know if
you know over time it's it's imbalanced
on one side more so than the other
obviously that's an imbalance and it's
the same way in the market right as the
markets moving down you can see here
it's mostly selling imbalances as the
market starts moving up you got buying
imbalances now you know there's other
ways to analyze this which I'll get into
in a bit you know this is just sort of
the basic part and you want to
understand that you know you have more
aggressive selling in a bar it's you
know that's important information you
know sometimes people will think that
it's it's important it's easy to tell
but what you want you know do you want
something that's definite or do you want
something that you're trying to discern
that you know hey I got a dress of mine
people say well you got red candles so
obviously sellers are in control yeah
okay but then you know at some point the
markets gonna stop and it's gonna start
going back and forth back and forth what
you want to know when a markets or a
pause is you know on a sharp move down
it's easy right you don't need order
flow if you just see big red candles on
the way down yeah selling sellers are in
control but it's when you hit that low
markets you gotta be asking yourself
when you hit a low you know is the
market gonna turn around you know you
got your first green bar here you want
to know are we gonna pause or we're
gonna start you know go sideways are we
going to rally back up are we going to
sell off some more and that's where the
order flow part comes in you know you
can see as you come into this low you've
got you know stacked mine and balances
in two bars right off the low that's
important information so Delta is
another part of water flow and Delta is
the difference between aggressive buyers
and aggressive sellers in a bar and it's
important because you want to know who's
dominating that bar and usually Delta
you know on my software on the order
flows trader it'll runs along the bottom
right some will like to put it above and
below the bar it's just neater I think
keep it along the bottom and you'll see
each bar has a delta right either it's
going to be positive or negative it can
be zero zero - I don't think means
anything just
neutral ballot buyers and sellers are
evenly matched and you know it does it
you know there's not some hidden secret
in a delta that ends in zero I could end
in one or two you know it's not like
under than zero that means I have to
like a doji very rare but it does happen
don't get don't get too excited about it
but again in generally speaking speaking
one of markets moving down you're gonna
have negative Delta's one of markets
moving up you know how positive deltas
and there's all there's different types
of Delta you have a max Delta you have a
min Delta Max Delta is how strong the
Delta was in a bar at one point and min
Delta is how negative Delta was at one
point in a bar and there's ways to
analyze that as well point control in a
bar is the price level with the most
volume right there's no mathematical
formula to determine it other than
simple arithmetic what you do is you
take the price level in the bar add up
both sides and if that level has the
most volume that's your point of control
for the bar and why is that important
because that's gonna give you real time
market generated support and resistance
levels and also on a bar by bar basis
you know you know as a trader right you
one of the age-old questions is well I
wish I knew why this price why this bar
that R in retraces back up to a previous
level in the previous bar because that's
where value was in the previous bar and
as you can see as the markets moving
down you're gonna have lower pointed
controls because that's your value area
in the bar as the markets moving up
you're starting to see important
controls moving higher and one of the
things that we've done with the order
flows trader is there are certain times
where point control is important I call
it a prominent point of control and will
highlight it you know with a blue a blue
background point of control in each bar
is going to be a gray but my software
will highlight it with blue if it's a
support area or red I don't have one on
this chart if it's a resistance area and
it's important because again it's going
to give you support or resistance
and a real-time level right it's it's
you know people like to think of support
and resistance you know when a market
comes backs and tests a level well did
this market come back and test this
level no but when the market sold off
based on the order flow I no other
support down here I don't have to wait
here come back to 27 12 to confirm I got
support here no I know in the order flow
that there is support there and the
market starts moving back up you know so
that's why that's important again you
know here's a better example here's your
prominent point of control you know a
bearish one here's a bullish one and you
can see how oftentimes the markets
especially in markets really driven by
supply and demand
deep markets in the sense of heavy
volume II like bonds and it works great
on buns it works great on you could find
these turning points just like this
right you got a high up here then it
sells off through this low and you got a
primary point of control then at rallies
back up here no again you know most
people the way they would look at
support or resistance they like okay
well we have this level up here we're
gonna wait for it to come back up here
and then if it comes back up here I'd
only get short again well why not trade
it now when it happens just as this one
here why wait you know you're missing a
great trade lower and a great trade back
up to that level you know that's the
thing which I'll get into later ziz
people like to wait for confirmation you
know when you should be trading the
market right you got to get up off the
bench and start trading rather than
sitting around waiting for confirmation
of this or confirmation of that
understand what's happening in the
market yeah yeah I got a problem
opponent control up here
I got a resistance area I could get
short down here I got a support area I
got a prominent point of control I could
get long I don't need to wait for this
market to rather you know from 2692
sell-off and rally back up to 2690 for
me to get short I know I can get short
up here 2688 you know what to stop just
above that high and what look at that
you know 2688 down to you know 2670 down
in here and then catch the move back up
as well you know rather than sit here
twiddling your thumbs waiting for the
market to come back to give you
confirmation
you've got eight points there eight
points back up all right that's what
traders do they trade now trap traders
is the next one I'll talk about in trap
traders our areas where traders are long
and wrong or they're short in the hole
you know you we've all done it we've all
sold the low then we got a bit chilly
and get out and or you know we've all
bought a high and then the market sells
off and you got to get out right that
adds to the move away from you know the
initial position like say you're long
and wrong you bought the high at twenty
six ninety I think the markets going
higher then the market starts trading 88
87 you know like I gotta get out
then you sell it so you know when
traders are trapped that causes you know
it's sort of like adding fuel to the
fire so to speak it makes the move in
the opposite direction stronger and with
you're looking at a bar chart can you
really determine you know if traders are
trapped if you're looking at a chart
like this can you say well there's
trapped traders up here how can you do
that you can't right you're just making
the guess to suit your narrative but if
you're looking at order flow you know
you can determine if there are by
looking at what's actually being traded
and again you know trap traders is
something I've always liked to look for
in the markets and we put it into the
software to show us where traders are
being trapped in the sense that they're
long and wronged or short in the hole
and you know honestly trap traders is
more of a short term thing don't think
of it as you know start of some massive
trend I mean even though even though in
this chart you know you could see it up
here at this high and then you're a big
sell-off really often times it's more
short-term than that and you can also
see trapped traders you know people in a
rising market you know in a market
that's trending already because what's
happening is you know the market starts
moving up and traders the guy you know
we're gonna go back test that low and
they start selling and then they get
stuck they got a cover getting short
cover it and get short again cover it
get short again cover it get short again
cover it so you often see it as well in
once a trend is underway
now market sweeps you know what kid
sweeps are interesting because it's one
of those things that not necessarily
everybody thinks happens in the market
but they do you know the reason why a
lot of people don't think sweeps happen
is because they've never traded on an
institutional level and actually the old
NYMEX Comex access system actually had a
function for sweeping the market where
you could enter a bid or an offer
several levels through the price and it
would just buy or sell everything there
and why is it used
well it's used by traders that want to
wipe out all the bids or offers you know
it's a certain price level because they
think the market is going to move and
they want to get everything on that they
can as quickly as they can and you know
some people will say well no one's ever
gonna buy through the offer no it does
happen it happens very often especially
in markets like crude oil
you know markets where people are doing
deals in the physical product and then
they're gonna do something in the
futures either too because they know the
direction of the market that the
physical is going in and futures will
follow so they're gonna use it to you
know add you know make extra money so
you know imagine somebody or your work
for BP or stat oil and you just do a big
deal in the physical market and you know
that's gonna have once that news gets
out it's gonna affect the the futures
market you know coming you know sweep
the market you know I would see it a lot
in markets like cotton especially if you
watch cotton overnight you know if
there's news coming out of China next
thing you know cotton is is down two
points then somebody sweeps the market
to limit up like within 15 seconds they
just buy everything that's in there then
next thing you know markets limit up and
it's limit up all day into the day
session and it happens more often than
people care to admit and you know it
think about it institutional trader
institutional traders you know have big
ticket sizes you know they got to trade
2000s and peas they're not just going to
when they get their fill basically
they're not concerned with why I bought
75 at this price 87 at this price 250 at
this price they just look at the average
price and if you
buying two and a half thousand SPS email
ease the market is you know twenty seven
twenty seven and a quarter at twenty
seven twenty seven and a half they see
they could buy everything I think you
basically get filled all the way up to
twenty seven twenty eight you know and
have an average of around twenty seven
twenty twenty seven twenty seven spot
two seven they're happy to do that okay
because they know that they're buying is
gonna move the market and so if they
could get their average price on their
fill below where the market is gonna end
up then they're happy to do that in the
order flows trader software the order
flows 2.0 trader is the only trading
software that's gonna show sweeping
activity and you can see how it is here
i market selling off just going sideways
and someone comes in sweeps the market
down next thing you know you got to
follow through though the market sells
off I mean here's another example yet a
sweep here okay a market didn't really
go anywhere then the market starts
moving again you got another sweep
happening for right before the market
sells off you know it's not every time a
sweep happens that it's gonna be
guaranteed that the markets gonna move
in that direction you know sometimes the
markets gonna you know what's gonna
happen if someone sweeps through the
bids or sweeps through the offers mark
is gonna pause people are gonna come
back in bid again then maybe their sweep
the second time around like you can see
here isn't gonna be so obvious cuz now
you got more more volume in the in the
bids and the offers but oftentimes it's
it's a nice indicator so nice it's a
leading indicator but you know it's
telling me that there's some sweeping
activity coming through in the market
right before it's gonna make a move now
hopefully you can understand the other
different aspects of order flow analysis
such as point of control Delta
imbalances and other information is very
useful tool for assessing the market for
identifying and evaluating trading
opportunities perhaps the most important
adding order flow to your trading
arsenal will help you find
trades that the public misses you know
that's the power of order flow you know
if you're looking at our normal bar
chart you're not gonna see where people
are sweeping the market not gonna see
where traders are trapped you can see if
there's an internal level you know
are acting as support yeah you're just
not gonna see that information on a
normal bar chart so the big advantage of
this for order flow trader software
users they don't have to make any of
those calculations you know they can
just look at the chart and understand
okay yeah there's a sweep just happened
here and react to it or you know it
looks like there's trap traders here and
react to it you know the order flow
Strader software automatically plots all
the traded volume for easy for every
market and time frame in a simple and
easy to read format so the next thing i
want to talk about are what our hidden
price movements and how to see them with
order flow and you know traders would
rather hide their activities in the
market then tell everybody hey look me
I'm buying in you know this big order I
want to get it done and I'm gonna move
the market and it's a bit like zebras
you know I I asked my son the other day
and why does zebras have stripes and he
says well so he's four years old granted
he said you know hit me with an answer
that I wasn't expecting he said well
that's so you can tell them apart from
horses and so okay I didn't think of
that
but the reason zebras have spots you
know if you've ever been to the Safari
here in Africa it's not a bunch of black
and white stripes you know it's not a
grass it's green color often you know
even though you turn on the news and you
think everywhere in Africa is is it a
drought and famine it's actually you
know lots of places there that have a
lot of green and trust me black and
white stripes stick out on green but as
you bros you know are herd animals and
if you're a lion and you're looking to
you're hungry right and you see zebra
but then you see another's you know you
see a big pack of zebras it's like an
optical illusion it looks much bigger
than one zebra alone and it's like that
with the markets you know you oftentimes
see so much volume through and going
through that you don't want to make any
decision but if you were to throw you
know white paint on one zebra it's gonna
stick out and there's gonna be times in
the order flow we're trading activity
just sticks out so if you're looking at
a bar chart alright
this this area down in here where the
box is you can see how the market
reversed and if you're looking at a bar
cart yeah I didn't know that this market
reversed or it's gonna start reversing
until it makes the reverse you know
people say oh I can just draw a
trendline up here and if we break that
yeah you know it we're reversing well
won't you rather know down here at the
bottom that something's happening that's
gonna be causing it to reverse and rally
back up and if you understand order flow
you can see that happening you can see
imbalances multiple imbalances coming in
here that's what this you know I didn't
talk about it just now but um one of the
things the order flow trader software
does is it will put a box around a bar
that has multiple imbalances and what
that means is more than one in more than
three imbalances in a bar you know with
imbalances there's what they call
stacked imbalance which is three
imbalances just neatly stacked on top of
each other like you see here this this
green area but you can notice here just
right the bar right after the low
there's you know this sort of purple box
right after it right around it at the
bar what that is that's a multiple
imbalance and it's telling me there's
more than three imbalances in there so I
know there's bars dominated by market
imbalances buying imbalances in this
case cuz either blue numbers and that's
important because we're coming down into
a low swing low here all the time seen a
lot of signs of aggressive buying coming
in so I can know that you know the
aggressive bonds here this is gonna give
me a great training opportunity right
down in here rather than you know if you
draw a trend line going down up here
through this swing high this lower high
this lower high yeah there's a three
line trendline but I can know down here
before you even get up you know way up
here that this is a buying opportunity
rather than waiting for this breakout
you know people like I said before you
know everyone likes to wait for
confirmation well if you understood how
to read the order flow
you got your confirmation excuse me so
here's another bar another bar chart and
again you know similar
all right you got this swing loan the
market starts rallying again you know
people so we just draw a trendline here
you break out there or you know you got
this stored candle well if you can read
the order flow and what's going on you
have a divergence so you got positive
Delta on a new low you have a bullish
ratio you know I've done a lot of videos
on this ratio analysis that's what these
blue numbers are above or below or the
black numbers above or below a blue
number is something that's important and
you know that that's what I when I first
really sort of flow straighter softer to
me that was the most important part of
it and it's still important and there's
these ratios and divergence which is
like a bread and butter trade I've go to
my youtube channel I've got tons of
videos on these and you know it's day in
day out it's a great tool for finding
highs or lows and if you knew I'm down
in here as you're making this new low
right you guys gotta be asking is this
low gonna hold or we're gonna go lower
we come down in here and I see hey we
got divergence and we've got a bullish
ratio to me that's go time you know
that's the signal that I need to get
long and you can see how the market
rallies up in 2676 all the way up to you
know 2688 you know here's another
example again you got that swing low
rally up to it this high up here but if
you look at the order flow you know it's
actually the low of the day you've got a
prominent point of control that's this
blue bar here this blue box you got the
bullish ratio this blue number you got
the divergence and you also had a setup
here also this is a ratio set up three
in a row you know where you would get
long is on the pullback to this point of
control down here
you know from 2690 all the way up to
this point control up here at 27 you
know oh six up here 2708 so then the
market sells off from this bearish point
of control goes down again but again
yeah any time you're coming into a low
or a high you know you want to be asking
yourself you know is this low going to
hold it what's the signs in the order
for this low is gonna hold and it's
there and you can see how the market
rallies up from this low all the way up
to this high and sells off from this
height
so you know and what's interesting is
you know a lot of these charts they look
alike you know when markets may close or
highs they really look alike and
understanding what's happening in the
order flow is this gonna put you ahead
of everybody else because you're gonna
understand that hey you know what this
this can be a low forming I can see it
happening in the order flow now here's a
you know we sell-off
rally back up up in here and then we
sell-off again okay and if you can read
the order flow you know this again it's
gonna put you head and shoulders above
the rest of the traders out there and
again you know this market is going up
right you got stacked behind imbalances
got multiple imbalances here you even
got a multiple imbalance in the stack
mine and balance in the bar then what
happens why isn't this market coin
higher that's the question you should be
asking yourself when you're sitting here
we look at a normal bar chart okay we
start reeling up you know big green bars
that's bullish right you know a lot of
buying going on you got a small red
candle here another small red candle a
doji and green candle and then WHAM it
just gets slammed right here here here
you know what's the clues well if you
could understand order flow you
understand that after you make this high
aggressive selling starts coming in in
this bar you can see multiple imbalances
this bar here multiple imbalances you
got one two three four five six seven
levels in this bar with imbalances so
you know maybe this first bar here with
the multiple imbalances you're not
convinced yet cuz honestly it's kind of
early and you just came on the back of a
lot of aggressive selling but when you
see this bar here where the bar is it's
half selling imbalances it seems that's
your sign to get short you know right as
it's coming off you know makes this
sell-off from 27:33 down to 27 22 just
like that you know I mean that's the
beauty of order flow is it allows you to
make those decisions in real time not
waiting oh you know why I gotta wait
till we break this line down here or
something or you know we gotta come back
up to this high test it and then sell
off now let's allowing you to make those
decisions right now
another example mark is going up comes
off a little bit goes back up BAM
makes the big sell-off this is crude oil
you know sells off from 5615 all the way
down to 55 76 55 65 and again markets
going up you can see trap traders coming
in here right you see them buying sweeps
coming in here as well so you know
there's traders that were trying to sell
down here and they're getting stuck and
they're covering it then you see people
sweep in the market on the way back up
you get up here you got a bearish point
of control
market does sell-off a little bit over
the next two bars rallies back up makes
a new high okay that's the training is
it you say ok you take a position okay
look I've had bearish morning control
and get short I get short ok comes back
up here I get stopped out you gotta be
astute and take the next trading
opportunity that it comes you know don't
sit here think I just took a trade I
lost I want to stop trading for a while
no you gotta keep trading you know it's
it's you gotta keep focus you know when
you golf you hit a bad shot you shank it
off off the tee you know say uh I could
I'm not gonna golf the rest of the day
no you keep golfing you know a pitcher
playing baseball gives up a home run he
doesn't say hey coach come in here take
me out no he goes back and he keeps
pitching and we're trading being
successful is accepting that you threw a
bad pitch accepting that you hit a bad
tee shot and you keep going because
what's gonna happen is this is gonna
happen you come back up
you made the new high here bearish point
of control poor bearish primary point of
control multiple imbalances you have
stacked imbalance okay now this is
looking like an even better selling
opportunity than it is here
so you willing to take the shot you know
where you gonna get stopped out you
gonna put your stop just above the high
of this bar then the market makes that
move right it's making the move now you
know it's just unfortunate it didn't
happen initially on the first bar but
now you're starting to see all the
aggressive selling coming in here
coupled with the resistance up here in
the point of control and then the market
sells off that's the move that you want
it unfortunately just didn't happen here
but again you know not every trade you
take is gonna be a guaranteed winner
just as every key shot you make or every
pitch you make it's going to be
you know the perfect pitch or the
perfect tee shot so the last thing I
want to cover in depth here is what's
known what no one is going to tell you
about becoming a successful trader and
this is just reality okay trading
systems and methods are viewed as
magical by their users you know by
people that buy them they think this is
it I'm gonna find the road to the riches
just now and honestly you know if if
you're thinking you know that's what
poor flow is gonna do for me you can as
long as you apply yourself as long as
you take what you learn and apply it to
the markets and again that's why I said
earlier you know you know no two traders
are alike you know how you trade versus
you know your buddy trades is completely
different you know read market Wizards
there's you know 15 20 people in each
book they're all successful they all
have different ways to approach the
market and they come from different
backgrounds they come from different
education systems but what's important
is they applied themselves to the market
you know some people they like they like
to do lead out you know dilly-dally but
they like to try something for a week
doesn't work you know it's like
sometimes you talk to people there I've
been trading for 10 years you know and
I've just been breaking even is well
then you sit down you analyze what
they've been trained well six months
they've been trading this market six
months later they're trading something
else with a different form of analysis
they're not consistent be consistent and
you know I've seen it in my own
experience since I've started order
flows is you know people that buy the
software and failed with it you know
after a few weeks or a few days even
playing it didn't produce a signal or I
salute you know that isolated a trade no
you you have to take the information and
make a decision you know it's a tool for
analyzing the market you know it's like
you buy a hammer right a hammer is there
to do a certain job right you can't saw
a piece of wood with a hammer you could
view the hammer bang a nail doesn't mean
a saw is useless no saws got its own
it's got its own used and software like
order flows trader it's not a system
rather what it does is it takes the
information available to everyone and
allows you to view it better
right that's how you get an edge over
other people's you take the information
that's out there and you analyze it how
other people aren't analyzing it that
makes sense and meaning a successful
trader takes work on your part you know
the people who buy order photo trading
software whether it's mine or not or you
know ofa or anything else and Phil do so
because they think they're buying an
easy pie-in-the-sky get-rich-quick
magical formula people that don't fail
want to understand what's happening in
the market so they can make intelligent
trading decisions you know people that
you know people often think that you
know purchasing an indicator is like a
magical device that's gonna feed them
sue them trainer typers even it's it's
and that's not what it's for it's to
help you make better trading decisions
so you know once you understand order
flow really looking at a chart you could
understand what's happening in the
market and you can make better decisions
like I said before trading is about
making decisions and you know here you
can see the market is selling off and
what's happening is - selling off you're
seeing stacked imbalances multiple
imbalances you see negative Delta's
appearing then you come into a low and
now you're starting to see positive
Delta's you're starting to see buying
imbalances stacked mine imbalances
multiple imbalances bullish ratios and
you know I even cover you know different
forms of analysis of Delta that you can
see forming down here this this is also
very bullish as the market starts going
back up so what you're doing is you're
reacting and the way I like to describe
it it's like driving a car you know you
internalize what's happening in the
market just as you internalize the flow
of traffic you know when you drive you
don't sit here and think you know I got
a pull onto the expressway what am I
supposed to do you know what to do you
know you know if there's a truck coming
that you better slow down and stuff like
that and with order file you see it you
see what's happening in the market you
know market rallies up to where a
bearish Brahman opponent control market
sells off starts rolling back up why is
because you got multiple buying
imbalances in here you got strong
positive Delta markets just go sideways
and embarrass a bullish prominent point
of control here some positive Delta the
market moves back higher and so
and that's what order flow allows you to
do it allows you to see what's happening
in the markets so hopefully by now you
can see how important order flow
analysis is and you know if you're
interested in this you know you're gonna
love the order flows trader software
package that I have for you
and what it is it's I call it the order
flows trader 2.0 and it runs on
ninjatrader 8 not ninja trader 7 if
you're on a ninja trader 7 get on
ninjatrader 8 now it's free to upgrade
but um you know if you're on
sierracharts go to a Moche trading tell
them I sent you and talk to Lee over
there they'll look you up with the
bonuses is what you get is the order
flows trader software with the volume
footprint chart with the 7
pre-programmed indicators I talked about
today I only I didn't talk about all of
them I talked about thing four of them
and basically what is is like having me
sit next to you telling you what's
happening in the order flow and also
you're gonna have an invitation to our
weekly live group trainings we meet
Monday night's 7:00 p.m. Central time
and I talk about order flow you know I
thought about what I've seen in the
markets maybe sometimes I talk about new
developments or new forms of analysis
and it's a great place to learn more
about order flow on a recurring basis
yes I'll get my chart template you know
so your chart can look like my chart
right that's what you want or you want
to be able to look at a chart quickly
right you want to see what's happening
in the market rather than spend all your
time trying to set up your chart alright
yeah it's frustrating honestly with new
software trying to figure it out so with
my template you get up to speed very
quick and normally I sell us for $8.99
but you're not gonna pay that today now
heavy an order flow software is one
thing right you have to know how to use
it and like I just said you know
sometimes we've all bought software in
the past and we can't figure out how to
use it and thing with order full
software is it's about how to read
what's happening in the market so what I
also offer you is I offer you education
on understanding order flow and to me
that's that's important part of trading
right so what you get when you get the
software for free
normally I sell this for 297 you know
peep
by it pretty much every day and it's the
order for trading course it's 20 lessons
15 hours of video instruction you get
access to that for free so that you can
start to learn more about order flow
what everything means and start putting
it together now if you're watching this
presentation I know that you're really
interested in understanding order flow
so I also give you is access to the
order flows inner circle video series
which is a series of 56 videos on
advanced order flow tricks tips and
analysis because really what this is you
know the order flows trading course is
is the basically on the college level
first-year college level course whereas
the inner circle video series is more of
you know the the junior or senior year
college level course on trading with
order flow you know this takes what you
learn here in the first course it takes
everything to a whole other level and
you start adding this all together at
eight ninety nine for the software to 97
for the order flow trading course for 97
for the inner circle video series it
comes out to almost seventeen hundred
dollars you know that's sixteen ninety
three and as a special a special bonus
for those of you that watch this
presentation through investor
inspiration you and get access to the
trader kickstart course which is
normally sell for 297 but you think get
it for free today and what it is it's it
deals with the mindset of trading you
know why traders succeed why traders
fail you know how to improve yourself as
a trader it deals with the psychological
side so that you can understand yourself
and where you are now and where you need
to be in the future so you add all that
together it comes out to just about two
thousand dollars it's nineteen nineteen
nineteen ninety it's just $10 off 2000
but you now can pay that you just gonna
pay a one-time payment of $7.99 and you
know there's no monthly payments or
other payments in the future of course
you'll need to pay your data fees or
NinjaTrader fees but there's no other
payments after that so just think of
that training of the education that
you're getting alone as well well worth
the price of admission in addition to
the software so what you do is you go to
order flow is calm slash off to HTML and
it'll take you to the page you know take
you where you can go to join
you know and you know watching my
presentation is one thing you know but
you know listen to what other people are
saying you know this is Sheila writes
the order flow straighter software is
remarkably helpful I can clearly see now
what's happening in the market like for
example who's in control the market on a
very specific time and who's getting
weaker as well what she do is to go to
order flows dot-com / off to takes it to
this page there's a couple of videos
there's a lot of examples on the page
you just scroll down and it takes you to
the sign up page click here by now I
want this you know it's handled got a
couple of payment processors ones PayPal
the others are stripe you know the
legitimate payment processors I don't
get your credit card I don't want your
credit card information you know you
could pay by a check even but you had to
ask yourself you know why do you want to
join order flows is because you see the
power of order flow analysis and how it
can change your trading you want to
understand what's happening in the
markets you know you're excited to find
low risk training opportunities you know
where you're risky and just a few ticks
in some cases per trade but most
importantly you want a life of freedom
and fulfillment you know that's why I
think you know to me that's the most
important part of trading is what comes
after after the trading day you know you
get to sit down with your family and the
beauty is you know if you want to do
stuff with your family you don't have to
trade that day you know the markets are
open you know everybody pretty much
every business day so there's plenty of
opportunities when you want to take time
off you can take time off you're your
own boss it gives you that freedom and
fulfillment of understanding what's
happening in the market so go to order
flows calms less off - and it takes you
to the page so just you know act now you
gotta ask yourself where you are now
where you were six months ago are you at
the same spot where were you a year ago
when you're trading you are you still at
the same spot water difference what's
are you gonna do to make a difference in
your trading you got to get up off your
ass sometimes and take the initiative
you got to start learning how to trade
be successful in life you know it's not
gonna just come and fall in your lap you
gotta take steps to become successful
whether it's in trading or any other
business that you're gonna run you know
you got to take that first step
so thanks Joe I'll throw it back to you
you know thanks everyone go to order
flows calm
off to again you know if you want to
watch more about order flow go to my
youtube channel go search order flows on
YouTube and you know some sure to
subscribe but again you know I put up a
lot of videos in the past I got a couple
hundred videos on there but you know on
many different aspects of order flow and
hopefully yeah you can watch that and
some things you know you'll pick up
something and say you know what now I
really understand the power of order
flow that you know I should be adding it
to my trading and again you know stop
flushing your money down the toilet you
know don't be every other week buying
some new fancy trading indicator then
you know wasting your money because you
can't get it to work properly or you
know you think it's some system that's
gonna turn you into you know some
millionaire overnight know you know
better off investing that money in
yourself learning how to trade learning
about what's happening in the market so
you could make good trading decisions
you know once you learn something you
know then we can take that away you know
it's the education invest in yourself so
again you know go to order flows calm
/off to and it take you to the sign up
page you know join yeah I think it's
well worth it and it's not overly
expensive you can you know finance it if
you you you'll have a credit card but
you know at the end of the day you have
to take that first step you know I could
tell you all the benefits of trading
order flow but until you see it
firsthand
that's when you'll understand it so go
to order flows calm slash off too and
you know have a great weekend everyone
and I'll catch you guys on the next
presentation bye-bye